why would anyone want to wage a war on
Merit hey
Merit is not fair so what is fair fair
is everybody having the same out
we have in the U in the US we have these
like gifted and talented schools and
they're trying to limit how many Asian
kids get to go because there's just too
many so what is the state of education
at the moment in public and private it
is pretty dire uh the woke have marched
through our institutions and they have
taken over schools at pretty much every
level you see this also with pornography
and school libraries that's become a
huge thing
yeah do you mean pornography pornography
in school libraries has become a giant
thing in the U.S because what do you
mean this breaks every single
safeguarding guideline that I have ever
heard
foreign
[Music]
ometry on the road from the USA I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is the
co-author of this book stolen youth
Carol Marcus welcome to trigonometry
thanks guys nice to be here it is great
to have you here and by the way thank
you to our locals for Lending us the
studio in Miami so we could do this this
was this is great
um listen uh the same question as we
always ask all our guests is who are you
what's been your journey through life
how do you find yourself sitting here
talking to us
post for over a decade and I also write
for a lot of other places
and I moved to Florida which is where we
are about a year ago very publicly
because I had been a lifelong New York
supremacist and really always defended
New York City against all slights you
know real and perceived and about a year
and a year and a bit ago my our family
decided that we had had enough the
schools had been closed the masks had
been on kids for too long the wokeness
had overrun everything reality had
ceased to exist for a lot of our
neighbors and we had to get out so that
is how we're sitting here in Florida
today and the book is an outgrowth of
that as well yeah and before that your
family moved here from the Soviet Union
that's right we were thinking about
doing this interview in Russian but you
know I thought that might be not my
Russian
yeah it's also iffy time to be Russian
yes that's right that's right so I've
been reading the book I find it very
interesting uh this is a moment every
trigonometry viewer and listen is going
to drink because I'm a former teacher
and I was reading about what's happening
in education in the United States it
sounds terrifying to put it mildly so
what is the state of education at the
moment in public schools in the U.S in
public and private it is pretty dire uh
the walk have marched through our
institutions and they have taken over
schools at pretty much every level
um it begins in teachers colleges where
the teachers themselves are
indoctrinated into leftist philosophy
they use Marxist books to teach the
teachers a lot of times the teachers
don't even know that they're being
indoctrinated and then these teachers
disperse throughout the country and end
up arguing things like math is racist
and this is reality that's happening in
schools across the country and I I do
note that it is public and private
because I think one of the main
solutions to all of this in America has
been school choice where you get the
portion of the funding that would have
gone to educate your child in a public
school you could take that funding and
go to private or parochial or Etc the
issue with that is that it's very hard
to find private and parochial schools
that are also not woke it's a minority
of schools across the country that
haven't been ideologically captured
Carol if I'm listening to this I'm not
someone who is clued up on all this what
we don't even know what work means it
almost sounds like a bit of a parody you
know the woke people have taken over the
institutions they've Brainwashed the
teachers like what does that mean yeah
you know the the subtitle to the book is
how radicals are raising innocence and
indoctrinating children
what's actually if I'm a parent I don't
care about the stuff I've got a job what
what's going on in the school that I
should care about so that used to be me
you know I think before writing this
book I would have said that a lot of
this stuff sounds like a conspiracy
theory and I don't know that I thought
that I was going to find what we found
while writing this I am a very
optimistic everybody kind of wants the
best for everyone and come on you know
obviously they're not teaching Marxism
at teachers colleges that's crazy
Constantine so you know it ends up being
something that's very hard to convince
people
um and I would have been one of those
people had I not seen what I saw in
writing this book so what I say to
parents is you know something
questionable is going on you might not
have a label for it it might you might
not call it woke woke is to me
when leftism meets a forced Conformity
that's how I describe bulkism
um so the old leftism might
sure they might indoctrinate your kids
or try to they might try to put in
information that is really one-sided
into curriculums yes but the new wokism
does that and also does not allow
stepping outside of the lines whatsoever
they do not allow other opinions they do
not allow other influences or
considerations so while the old leftist
teacher might you know paint a picture
let's say of America as being this like
terrible place where we just you know
slaughtered the Native Americans and
stole all their land and we have nothing
positive about us at all they'll
sometimes they would often present the
opposite opinion as well now it's like
this is what we believe we believe this
now and what I say often also is that
Liberals are hardest hit by this it's
not really conservatives like me I don't
really care what they say and I could
brush it off and that's it but for
liberals they've gotten to where they're
very scared to speak and their liberal
teachers are very scared to speak they
don't want to say the wrong thing they
don't want to be ostracized by their um
tribe and so you have this conformist
thinking that is you know has taken over
everything and I think parents recognize
it and they might not be able to label
it or name it but they know it's
happening and the reason I asked this
because I think there are quite a few
people now who feel this way like Dave
Rubin had me on his show on this very
set yesterday we recorded it and we're
talking about will we ever move to
America and why and why not Etc and one
of the things I was saying is you know
the one thing is at children's education
that is terrifying because you you know
this as a mother like you give birth to
this little thing and you raise it you
nurture it and then you know they're not
that old when you send them off to be
you know brainwashed by people and it is
quite scary I think for a lot of parents
but I suppose the question is prac on a
practical level what can you tell us
about what children in this country are
being taught at school that should
concern people
so it's interesting I lived in the UK I
started telling you guys this before the
show started but I lived in Scotland and
the first time I lived there apologies I
really loved it and I loved um and I
moved there because I had just fallen in
love with the country but I moved uh the
first time to study on a commune in
Scotland in the north of Scotland open
conservative lived on a commune all my
you know flatmates knew who I was and
what I believed and maybe that could
still happen in Scotland I don't know
that cannot happen in America not only
forget about the commune you cannot have
flatmates who have different political
beliefs than you do currently in the U.S
it just isn't like when you have ads for
roommates and newspapers it'll say you
know no no conservatives or no you know
trumpers or no just no not anybody who
doesn't believe what we believe
um so all of that is scary to me that
kind of Conformity I don't know if you
guys have gotten to there yet in the UK
I don't know that you worry about what
your kids are learning in school but for
me I have now seen something thing that
I can on C and I have to battle it at
home I was telling you that my kids
watched your Oxford Union speech because
to me I wanted to explain to them why
the rest of the world is not let's say
focusing on climate change the same way
that our 18 year olds are and why that
matters
um so at home we try to really lay the
foundation so that when they go out into
the world I'm not as worried about them
being ripe for indoctrination and Carol
what specific things are happening in
the classroom that you would say is
wrong and teachers shouldn't be teaching
well we have so many examples in the
book of things that teachers absolutely
shouldn't be teaching
um I you know I kind of joke about the
whole math is racist but that's
happening that is actually happening
where if you you know if you believe
that two plus two will always equal four
that is a racist construct and that is
does that really happen that is really
what happens I see idiots saying it on
Twitter but when people assert that is
is happening in school I'm like is it
yes we trace it to two teachers colleges
again they're learning this they're
they're learning the idea that two plus
two does not always equal four and if
you're adamant that it does that is a
racist construct a white supremacist
construct that you that you believe
um so many other things that go beyond
you know that kind of nonsense but we
keep hearing stories in the U.S of kids
being transitioned in the classroom
behind their parents backs where they
don't tell the parents that the little
girl is decided she's a little boy and
they give them a new name and they let
the kid bring in other clothes to wear
and we're talking you know when you
picture this you might be picturing like
a 16 year old but one of the recent
cases was a fourth grader which in the
U.S is around 9 10 years old
keeps happening it's not like one story
it's like dozens at this point
um and the idea that the teacher can
have a secret with your child is scary
and parents should be afraid because
maybe your child doesn't have gender
dysphoria and worry you know thinks that
they might be a different gender but
they could have other problems that the
teacher is going to keep from you and
decide that you're not worth you know
bringing into the conversation and that
should really scare people and Carol
look as someone again who used to work
in that sector
it's surely got to be a minority hasn't
it because just from my experiences of
teachers in a career that spanned what
12 to 13 years yeah
can't imagine that many of them behaving
in this fashion if I'm honest of course
then yeah of course it's a minority it
couldn't you know if we had
50 plus percent of the teachers across
the across the country deciding that
you're a kid you know might be of a
different gender and not telling you
about it I think that would really be a
bigger problem but it's happening and so
again it's it's like it could be one
thing it could be another thing at my
kid's school in Brooklyn
um getting the kids to March for
different causes has become standard
they have marched against guns they have
marched against hate vague hate they've
marched obviously for climate change you
know uh policies to be altered and I
tell a story in the book where I let my
first grader or my middle son March in
this climate March because we had just
switched schools after after the school
year had started he was already new and
different and I didn't want to speak up
and I would never you know it still
bothers me that I didn't say anything
because my little seven-year-old marched
around where the Earth dies we die sign
and then he came up with like ideas on
helicopters and caves and what he can do
to like fight climate change and you
wanted my first grader on it and now
he's on it and you know you could see
where this grows into anxiety for kids
and that is a giant problem so many kids
have issues because they are told that
the Earth is ending and you are tasked
with stopping it little seventh grade
seven year old you know and what I find
baffling is I'm I look at what sorry I
look at these things that are happening
in classrooms in the United States
and it might be more understandable if
your outcomes educational in this
country weren't appalling well that's
the whole thing right every minute you
spend on walk nonsense is a minute
you're not spending on math and science
and you know history that's a big issue
to me and you know being born in the
Soviet Union I think I have a very like
my kids must be very into academics like
I do not play
um you know you got a B minus word
you're like a Chinese yeah yeah I love
the you know tiger mom Amy Amy but I
don't I'm not I'm not as good at it as
she is like I you know but yes I
absolutely think academics is so
important and I want my kids to be
challenged I want things to be hard for
them I don't want them just skating by
which my kids love to do
um I want them to work and even that is
an idea that you're not allowed to have
anymore so in places like San Francisco
they're dumbing down their curriculums
because it's not fair to have let's say
an algebra class where the majority is
white and so because it's not fair
they're getting rid of like algebra for
seventh graders all together and this is
insanity this is crazy and the lack so
this um
I call it like the war on Merit really
goes hand in hand with this wokeness
because it's all one thing it's all like
we do it like this and this is how we
are going to push equity and this is how
it works and your assertion is that this
comes from the teacher training well
this part of it yes but it's it has
gripped so many different facets of our
society schools is just one chapter of
the book because so many other ways that
wokeness has woven itself into our world
again I don't know whether things are as
bad in the UK yet when I listen to you
you know I think that your universities
for sure are also captured but I don't
know that the rest of your Society has
been taken over quite as much as ours
has and so another example and the one
that I find just absolutely scariest in
the book like I think schools kids you
can you know education you could sort of
still reverse you can do stuff at home
you can build a block but the scariest
chapter for me is the medical chapter
where our medical system has been
entirely captured by this woke virus and
so for example every year there's like a
conference where the best doctors who
deal with premature birth babies get
together and they talk about it and they
have like the four absolute best to tell
you what happened in the last year
because things are always changing and
improving in the field and so they
recently had this conference or in about
a year and a half ago maybe and
they realized that the four best doctors
in this field are white men and you
can't have that so now they're going to
introduce women and make sure that the
ethnicity spread is is wider on the
stage but so now you no longer have the
best actors you have good doctors maybe
but you're looking for other things
other than best and that is so scary and
then in order to get into medical
schools you need to write an essay on
how you're going to promote diversity
and and the rest in your practice and
it's terrifying it to me that really
takes away the ability of a doctor to
say what they want to say investigate
what they need to investigate and really
not feel like they are
um you know have to conform to some
ideas it's it's such a good point
because with a doctor you don't want
them thinking about any of this nonsense
you just want them to treat you that's
it right and yeah and the gender thing
comes up in the medical thing too where
the doctor has to pretend that they
don't know what gender you are for real
and you know they have to give you tests
that don't apply to you because you know
you say that you're this gender and your
your birth sex is something different we
also keep coming across that and so it
just every minute that is spent on this
people people are going to die this is
going to lead to death we might not know
it we might not see it but it is going
to happen and of course because a woman
having a heart attack is very different
to a male having a heart attack
absolutely and the dosage that you have
to give and all the rest of it and
there's I mean a heart attack's a
perfect example because someone's having
a heart attack you don't have a lot of
time to then go I wonder what this
person with a vagina identifies as
that's exactly it and it's it that kind
of thing is really terrifying so my
co-author uh is the homeschooling mom of
six I have three kids I have two in
public one in private school and she
homeschools her children she pre-reads
the books she doesn't let them watch any
modern television or YouTube or anything
I'm much more permissive and for me we
kind of lay down the foundation at home
we we really talk about a lot of
different things that we wish we didn't
have to be talking about on a lot of
different levels but she'll say that no
matter how much she opts out of culture
she can't opt out of her pediatrician's
office and so this no matter how much
you want to pull your kids from this
Insanity you have to go to the doctor
sometimes and so you might not be
interested in woke you know but woke is
interested in you and how does this play
out against what I think is a very good
system again Dave and I talked about
this the federal system where you you
can do what you've done which is if you
don't like what's happening in the
jurisdiction that you live in you can
and move somewhere else like I are you
able in this country as an American to
go well I don't like this I am going to
move to wherever and there I can vote
for my school district or whatever to be
the way that I want is that still
possible or is this like you can't
escape it yes that is still possible in
some ways but the medical thing for
example that's a national accreditation
Society so it's not a local thing you
can't move to Florida you might you just
might find more doctors who don't
subscribe to this kind of thing and who
will do things you know in a normal way
even though they've been taught to do it
in an abnormal way you might find more
of them in places like Florida but they
have been accredited by the same
licensing groups that push this so it
and it's it's happening on such a wide
level that it's it's tough to find
rational sane doctors and you know even
in Florida we sort of have like a
whisper Network like is your doctor can
I have him like and that's the that's
how you find your md even here and I
know you left the Soviet Union at a
fairly young age younger I I think you
would you said you were two I was about
11 or 12. but I imagine you still know
you're familiar with the idea of living
in a society as we would have done it as
I certainly did where
your parents had to fight the the
authorities yeah to prevent you from
being indoctrinated into an ideology
that they thought was wrong or evil
frankly right right
do you feel that I look whenever you
make any comparison with anything people
like no yes yes but you know what I mean
do you think we're sort of operating in
a similar environment now where if you
don't agree with these ideas you have to
work so hard at home as a parent
just to prevent the children from being
basically ruined by the school that they
end up going to so we opened with a
history chapter in in stolen youth
because there is there are a lot of
parallels to what's happening right now
and I don't know about you my whole life
people have said like oh doesn't this
feel like the Soviet Union and I would
like no not at all that's not not even
comparable like what are you talking
about
um but the last three years the kovid
years have really felt Soviet and a lot
of in a lot of ways you know neighbors
and forming on each other you're not not
allowed to say certain things you you
must word things in a certain way the
spectacle of it like the black lives
matter and like the defund police in the
US like it wasn't enough to say it you
had to put the sign in the window you
have to really say it so um I see a lot
of parallels and so the difference is
that my parents would have worried about
getting into real trouble if they had
tried to tell me the truth
um we I tell the story of public in in
the book
um and you know my mom still does
yes and he was the he had told we don't
know which part of the story is true is
what I was going to say about public my
mom does not know which part of that
story is true we don't really it doesn't
matter which part of the story what
matters is this was a story that was
held up he this guy was a hero that's
what matters so he was a hero he had
informed on his parents for hoarding
grain and his Pat his family how so
let's just get the background to the
store for people who don't know how old
was the kid and when when was this it
said so this is um in the Stalin years
he's around 10.
um he is he he tells and again did he
tell on his parents or was he randomly
murdered we have no idea because
everything there is a lie but um The
Story Goes he informed on his parents
who had been hoarding grain and then his
family killed him and then in
retribution the state killed his entire
family his mother his father his cousins
his like everybody everybody gets killed
in the story the grandparents it's a
very Russian story yeah everybody dies
and then you call it a comedy like
checkoff
so he becomes Pioneer number one and
this is a story that they use to
indoctrinate other children look you can
be like public you can be a boy hero
um and you're told on his family yeah
who told on his family his family
matters far less than the state does so
here's the the perfect example and you
could be a hero or you could be dead in
a ditch like which one do you want to be
um and so yeah I think that a lot of the
you know I'm not saying again that we're
at the same place in the Western World
of the Soviet Union was but we are in
danger of it and I think that a lot of
the main thing to me is that in the
Soviet Union in China and Cambodia and a
lot of places that we write about in the
history chapter they could say we didn't
know and a lot of it is true they really
didn't know they didn't know what was
true they didn't know what was real but
we can't say that and part of that is
why we wrote the book we don't want
people to say oh I had no idea well
here's here's what's happening you have
the idea now and Carol one of the things
that I I find extraordinarily troubling
about the moment that we're in is
I'm not saying we ever got to the goal
because we didn't
but the aspiration for my generation and
probably you know people older than me
as well was we would in the west were
trying to get to a society where your
race didn't matter yeah I'm not saying
we got there there was still racist
[__] around when I was growing up
and still are but that was the dream
that was the goal that was the vision we
got that from Martin Luther King onwards
and it was universally embraced as the
way that a multi-ethnic society like the
ones that we live in shouldn't move
forward
and now I think it's fair to say that
the woke ideology
has the opposite of you Race Matters a
lot to people
so what do you how do you talk to to
your kids about that like if all they
see from the outside is race race race
really matters how do you how do you
teach them about it how do you talk to
them about we try to have really honest
conversations with them and that's the
thing parents are so awkward and they're
so afraid of saying the wrong thing to
their own kids I'm not afraid of that I
and I and neither is my husband I think
we we talk to our kids about how much
Character Matters and how the color of
somebody's skin is you know irrelevant
um and so many different ways that we
try to bring home the idea that you
cannot be colorblind it doesn't mean
that you're not you know you don't see
race of course you see race but you
treat everybody the same and you don't
you know treat anybody differently
because of their race in a positive or A
negative way
um and I think it's crazy that we've
moved away from that that used to be you
know it was it was the gold standard of
it again you're right we didn't get
there I'm not saying that we we lived in
some like racism-free Society that's
ridiculous but we were heading towards
something better and now we're heading
towards something far worse what are we
heading towards Carol we're heading
towards race being the absolute number
one most important thing about you and
you know what's interesting about that
is it's happening to white people too so
it is leading to an increase in like
white supremacist groups Etc if you tell
people your race is the most important
thing about you people are going to
believe you and so you know I I like to
say to my kids you know we're Jewish so
I'm like I don't know are we white like
who knows that this you know today we
might be yesterday we weren't and so
race really doesn't matter it's who you
are and I know it's cheesy as that
sounds like that's the message we should
be delivering to Children it absolutely
should be and also as well the
discrimination against Asian people
particularly when it comes to colleges
terrible it's mind-boggling it's going
you can't do this right and it's
spiraling past colleges so the thing is
that there's so many books about the way
the colleges have been this had this
ideology ideologically captured but it's
happening everywhere now we have in the
US we have these gifted and talented
schools and they're trying to limit how
many Asian kids get to go because
there's just too many too many you know
like the tiger moms are doing just too
good a job
um and it's interesting like you know
that they used to limit how many Jews
could go to different colleges for
similar reasons they still do but to a
lesser extent but now you won't even see
Jewish kids at these GNT schools because
priorities have changed and but you will
see Russian Jews and they're you know
they're pushing the same thing that the
Asian parents are the the you know
academics matters a lot and we expect
High things from you and we want you to
work hard and some taking this away from
people because they have the wrong skin
color because you didn't get the right
mix of skin color is just absurd have we
gotten to this place where
even something I mean that to me is nuts
the fact that you you literally say to
someone yeah you pass every every one of
our standards but you can't come in
because you're Asian right well then
they don't end up saying it to them so
there was a giant scandal in the US
um a few months ago like three or four
months ago where there's a school
um in Virginia called the Thomas
Jefferson and it was like the premier
gifted and talented school
um and high Asian population the
principle of several schools didn't tell
kids that they had qualified for a
National Merit Scholarship because they
were embarrassed that the majority of
the kids who had qualified were all
Asian and there just wasn't a good
racial mix so they didn't tell these
kids that they were going to get money
for college it's it like to me that
should be the huge story even today it
should just be every day like they took
away something from kids because they
were the wrong race and it was it was a
story for a few days days the governor
passed some rule a republican governor
passed a rule that now you must tell
them what if they qualified for a
national marriage scholarship like okay
that's I guess that's something but it's
not really making the kind of changes
that we should be making well it's
because it's reflecting a much deeper
thing that's going on in society which
is the re-racialization of society and
that that's where we come back to your
point about the war on Merit why would
anyone want to wage a war on Merit right
because
there is everybody having the same
outcome that's fair that's well that's
the word that they use they use equity
right it's not equality Equity is a
standardization of outcomes it's not
about how much work you put in it's
everybody comes out the same I have
three kids they could not be more
different I will be shocked if they end
up anywhere near the same with you know
outputs they're going to have I'm sure
they're all going to do great but
they're going to do great in completely
different ways and if I try to apply the
equity standard to them like you three
must all come out virtually the same it
would be a tough tough haul well Thomas
Hall makes this point a lot which is how
can you possibly expect equity in
society when you can't expect Equity
within right people who share the same
genetic right base right
um but this this is also another thing
that reminds me of the Soviet I mean one
of the reasons the Soviet Union
collapsed was the the full the terrible
productivity that is produced by a
system in which you're not rewarded
right for merit yeah and the impact of
that sort of mindset on a society I mean
you've talked about doctors and that's
that's an obvious kind of coal-face
scenario but everywhere if if you run a
business by I mean we saw and we saw it
in the UK you know with the comedy
industry
um
mock the week which was a huge TV
program comedy program in the UK the
mass report which I I worked on for a
bit uh a a bunch of them uh I basically
have died and a big part of the reason
is they they went Uber into sort of
left-wing politics instead of doing
jokes right uh but also it's I think
it's objective objectively a fact that
they picked people to work on the show
based on their demographic
characteristics and not on their talent
and those shows don't exist anymore yeah
and I wouldn't want to be picked because
I'm a woman no I like that was I would
just find that so insulting I would want
to be the best at whatever it is I'm
doing I don't want to be you know oh we
gave the woman a job I find that really
you know
um insulting and so again I have a
daughter and two sons I'm teaching them
that they all better work and that they
have to you know produce and and be at
their very best and not just expect
doors to open for them you know the
sun's get it there nobody's opening the
doors but my daughter I'm thinking you
know I'm not waiting for somebody to
offer her opportunities just because
she's a girl and actually she turned
down an opportunity where
um there was a she's on a robotics team
they didn't make it to States and then
she was invited to join another robotics
team because they needed a girl and she
was like no thanks like I don't want to
be the girl on your team what does this
do to kids when you effectively say to
him it doesn't matter how hard you work
you're either going to achieve because
you come from a certain ethnic
background or you're not going to
achieve I really think it messes them up
and and not just you know not just about
the Merit thing but just in every way if
you're told that your accident of birth
is all that matters about you and things
that you had absolutely no control over
is is what's important
um I think you know one of the things
that I believe why so many teenagers are
non-binary now or you know switching
their gender I think it's because they
don't have any you know points in the in
the oppression meter and they want some
so non-binary is a really easy way to
get some you don't even need to change
anything you just have everybody call
you some new pronouns and now you're
oppressed now you get to be part of the
club and I always say that if this was
happening when I was a teenager no doubt
in my mind you guys would have to be
calling me some pronoun you've never
heard of before I would oh I'd make it
up every day I would have my teachers I
could control my well my teachers call
me every day every day I can come in and
say I'm something else sure I would do
it yeah and a lot of power and you also
think as well what's going to happen to
this generation when they go into the
world of work
well we used to think that and then they
went into the world of work and the
world of work conformed to all this
nonsense and so I don't know I I it's
more like what is the world of work
gonna and what's gonna happen to them
when this new generation who have
pronouns are literally we have not heard
of yet
um goes to work so that's the problem is
that
this capture has happened so on so many
different levels that I think that these
people are running the place what's
interesting is and we point this out a
lot in the book and really I know I'm a
huge bummer usually but this is like on
my real optimistic point is that there's
still a real minority they're just
really loud and they they're able to
assert their their dominance and they're
able to push the kind of Conformity that
they require in order for this to work
if people in Mass said no if the Bill
Maher's and you know the other liberals
who who know that this is crazy would be
more vocal in pushing back this could
end tomorrow but people are not brave
they're afraid they don't want to be
called out they don't want to be
ostracized or shunned they're called
names and so they don't and you know I
think that's going to be step one well
one of the the elements of the book is
the idea of a raising innocence and the
thing that I see that makes me want to
get the flamethrower out frankly is
that's a metaphor by the way [__]
literal I want to get the Flames when I
see a drag queen in a g string twerking
in front of kids I want to get the
flamethrower yeah I get that because you
know this this conversation started with
drag queens Story Hour at your local
library and you know it's interesting
because I think that a lot of parents at
the time were like oh it's the big deal
it's like a clown reading to your kids
like who cares
um and then it spiraled into this
g-string thing where when's the last
time you saw them read a book to kids
like this drag queen Story Hour has
turned into drag queen twerking hour and
we're supposed to just accept it and
there's so many examples like that where
the slippery slope is just does not
allow for any kind of Middle Ground I
think that you know in the past I would
have said like oh I'll call people
whatever pronoun they they ask me but
then it went to they and that's already
iffy and then they went to luxur and I
don't even know what that is and now
like there are literally just so many
others I you can't keep playing this
game it's like you have to say no early
now and it's
it sucks because like I don't think I
cared when drag queen Story Hour first
hit I think I thought you know who cares
if you want if parents want to take
their kids to this whatever but now when
I see that you know the g-string
twerking I'm like no make that illegal
right now and where is that coming from
because I I don't understand I I don't I
don't yeah I'm getting old I don't
understand why why do children need to
be
exposed to obviously sexualized Behavior
I don't care if it's a drag queen I I
don't care if it's a stripper I don't
care if it's the metal drag creature
it's never going to be a stripper that's
the whole thing they get it they get you
or they get other people to say that
this is okay through using LGBT you know
um Community right because if you go
Stormy Daniels to tell me exactly nobody
would be like oh yeah this is important
right nobody thinks it's okay for a
woman to you know dance around in six
inch heels and a g-string for kids but a
man dressed as a woman becomes okay you
see this also with pornography in school
libraries that's become a huge thing
yeah what do you mean pornography
pornography in school libraries has
become a giant thing in the U.S because
what do you mean parents keep finding
pornography in their kids school library
what do you mean by pornography I mean
you it would shock you not like not like
you know I mean you haven't seen this
phone but
just a joke it's just
um it's books that literally talk about
show pictures of sex acts but yeah look
when I was a kid my parents when I was a
teenager gave me a book which was
educational about sex did it have
somebody on their knees and giving oral
sex uh no no no right so no
um and did it have like sexting in it
where two boys sexed each other dirty
pictures or ask for really graphic
things to be sent to them it didn't and
you would be again you would be shocked
and it's happening at elementary schools
so in the US again that's till fifth
grade that's 11 12 years old is where
elementary school ends in Florida
Governor DeSantis has made you know made
them go through all the libraries and
for this is called a book banner and
remove a certain uh these books that
they know that they exist right so he
sent out so he had a press conference
where he was talking about what books
they were getting rid of and he started
reading from these books and news
channels had to pull away from his press
conference because they can't show that
on TV they can't have that language on
so you can't show that to 10 year olds
but you can show that to 10 year olds
and The Quirk here is it's always always
a gay story
because you you know you can't show
straight sex at that age to kids but
somehow it becomes okay when it's a gay
story and this is how they are able to
protect themselves from a lot of
criticism because you know we're just
showing LGBT youth um you know stories
about them and this if you have a
problem with this you're a bigot Carol
you're not making this up are you swear
I'll I'll send you I will you can you
know I don't know if you're going to be
able to post the pictures but you will
be look up pornography elementary
schools Florida
Google history but Anton's our producer
mate we're going to do that on your
phone you have a look mate all right
yeah I hear you but we use the word they
and I think this is really important to
specify who are they there's a lot of
these
um I know I know that they it seems like
um I'm just I'm calling out some group
that doesn't some shadowy group that
doesn't exist but there's it comes from
a lot of different places
um so one of the examples again with one
of these pornographic books
um they're a 11 year old boy I think
around that age got up at a school board
meeting started reading from this book
again they're all shocked that please
stop speaking that's really disgusting
and they're like he's like I got this in
my Elementary School library he got it
from the librarian the librarian offered
him this book and then said if you like
it I have others like it
um yeah this is again happening where
it's at every level we have a chapter on
libraries and book publishing where
again
super woke completely ideologically
captured and pushing a very specific
agenda
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
this and now look I'm looking at it
through a UK teacher's lens and I go
back to my training this breaks every
single safeguarding guideline that I
have ever heard that I've ever heard
because if someone told me that a boy in
my class or a girl doesn't matter was
getting
content or books which have sexual
connotations and pornographic that to me
is grooming and I would have to report
it well and if I didn't report it I
would get in problem I would get in
trouble quite rightly so it's absolutely
grooming and it's grooming them to not
have a perspective on what safety is not
being able to say this doesn't feel
right to me because you're supposed to
be okay with all of it you must see
these books because the fact that you
haven't you haven't seen these I I don't
know if again I would love to hear if
this is happening in UK schools once you
see like the book titles because they're
really common here it's not like it's
not like two schools founded it's like
dozens and dozens of schools found it
just in Florida and in other states and
it's it's everywhere we we Sorry Francis
I just yeah go to follow up on that we
as far as I mean I didn't know you had
this here I don't know if we have in the
UK we did have
some kind of some a show that was
marketed to families with children that
was called I think the family sex show
sex show yeah family sex show in which
uh the actors were encouraged at one
point to remove items of clothing up to
and including full frontal nudity
and I still remember when we talked
about on the show the lines were I have
a penis in my pants touch it touch it
touch it
um yeah and why is this
why is this why where why is this
happening
why is it happening who wants to who is
it look I'm sorry in my day if somebody
wanted to sexualize children we knew
what that was right we had a name for
those people and we tried to arrest them
and put them in prison right why is this
happening now in our society so again
again why it's happening is to
know that that sounds I know how it
sounds I know it sounds like a
conspiracy theory who would want to mess
up kids but look in all these
totalitarian societies that was the goal
to unbalance the family to make the kids
all messed up and make them easier to
control so even though that sounds like
something that is crazy like who would
want to harm kids this is something that
has happened throughout history in so
many other places it's just unique that
it's happening here and now
um and then the idea of removing the
kids barriers and making them more awake
woke to everything that's going on is
absolutely part of it you know why have
kids protest why have kids do any of
this why have kids learn about grown-up
topics it's all to remove like the the
barrier of this is not for kids this is
not okay to do the children and if you
once you remove that barrier and kids
become your little activists who can be
any agenda could be pushed they're
really hard to argue with look at the
climate you know Greta it's impossible
to argue with her it's getting easier
she gets older but who's going to argue
with her when she was like a you know
adorable little crazy teenager and it's
we have that with gun control in the U.S
too like the teenagers who speak out on
guns um they're impossible to challenge
because they're kids and you don't want
to argue with children and this is the
thing that ends up happening Carol do
you think as well maybe we're projecting
a bit too much I'm not talking about the
the pornographic stuff because that's
vile but I'm talking about the other
things is it just that these people see
that they are to quote what they always
say on the right side of history and
that being the case it's only right that
we teach kids about what it means to be
on the right side of History then the
whole kind of indoctrination and mind
control do people really think that
deeply I'm going to be honest you I
don't think they do I think the reason
is this uh ideology is so powerful is it
makes you feel good it makes you feel
you're doing the right thing and if you
feel you're doing the right thing and
you feel good then you're gonna spread
it aren't you right but so which part
like you're saying the drag queens no no
not the dry creams no not the drugs
and again I'm so um but for instance not
with the climate if you genuinely
believe that that we're in a climate
emergency then why wouldn't you teach
kids do you see what I mean why why
would you teach kids that the Earth
might end soon like what are they going
to do about it other than not sleep at
night like I I I don't know no they're
going to stop using plastic straws yeah
and everything's gonna be fine right
right and when Britain can you know A
love referring to your speech but when
it sinks into the sea and nobody cares
like that it's still not going to make a
dent in climate change so there's no
real purpose of teaching kids about
adult issues unless you want them to
stress and and worry about it because
they can't do anything again I can send
you my son's you know plan from when he
was seven years old and how we're all
going to live in caves and you that's
what they end up coming up with they're
not like the smartest these
seven-year-olds well right and you know
on on this I mean you are right when I
was growing up we were also told you
know we're about to run out of oil we're
about to run out of coal where all of
these things I don't remember this level
of like intensity intensity anxiety you
know oh
that wasn't happening right so again had
we been having this conversation three
years ago I probably would be with you
like nobody thinks about this this
deeply this is crazy but so much has
changed in the last three years where I
do think so much of it is willful and it
is meant to mess the kids up and so many
people in charge or like Randy
Weingarten it basically runs schools
throughout the United States who's head
of the teachers union very powerful you
know at the Biden White House got to
write covet policy for whether schools
open or not not a scientist obviously
not a doctor just got to write policy
about whether kids get to go to school
doesn't have kids doesn't have any kind
of care about kids and yet she gets to
control so much of what happens to
children so do I think it's by Design I
do at this point it there's too many
coincidences here I think a lot of the
you know you were saying about
um The Grooming and whatever there's
other ways not just sexual grooming but
to groom them to accept different ideas
and to be able to immediately convince
them of things there's another kind of
grooming intellectual grooming but
that's what's happening also making them
believe that this set of ideas is the
only set of ideas allowed and and this
is what we're going to push to you yeah
and I look and I think that's a problem
plus as well you know one of the great
tragedies about education is that
education rapidly becomes political
because adults are political and unless
they have a real discipline they bring
politics into the classroom and the
problem is with doing that is kids
they can't they don't yet have the
capacity to take on an idea yeah to
break it down to analyze strengths and
weaknesses unless you teach them that
and that's another part of the problem
is that we don't teach critical thinking
in schools absolutely because you're not
allowed to why why would we allow
critical thinking in schools when we
need them to believe certain things that
we're telling them
um I we do a lot of critical thinking
stuff at home
um for us it's really important that my
kids can identify when somebody's trying
to convince them of something
um and and so my older two you know my
youngest is seven he doesn't count yet
but my older two are really they're woke
police they are like wait I heard
something is this something and and
often they're right
um sometimes they're not sometimes I'm
like no it's fine don't worry about that
um but they they're very careful about
what what gets told to them and I let
you know again my co-author protects her
kids from all media my kids are on
YouTube they're watching stuff and what
I end up discovering is that like they
because I let them watch whatever they
want they end up watching the world's
most wholesome stuff they are just like
the Mormon Channel
like oh this Mormon comedy skit with no
cursing at all or you know bad themes is
what my kids watch
um and Carol if people want more on that
I really recommend they read the book
stolen youth but I before we wrap up I
wanted to spend a few minutes I mean the
covert policies managed to achieve
something that's very difficult which is
to get some New York Jews to move out
right that used to be pretty hard
um what happened
well for us
um it was really what about around
schools that the schools were closed
only the public schools which is the
public schools in Britain I know mean
private schools but here are like our
local schools were closed but if you
paid 50 to 70 000 to go to private
school in New York City your schools
were open because they were covered safe
um and the thing was that our neighbors
had spent that summer of 2020 we lived
in a very left neighborhood which never
mattered it was fine we didn't care at
all it was like yeah we were open
conservatives we had friends you know
which we still do
um but it never mattered until then
where we watched them March for equity
and then not say one word when the
poorest kids in the city couldn't get
help couldn't go to school didn't get to
you know they my neighbors hired for
their own kids Tutors or they formed
pods or they moved to their beach house
and sent the kids to school there and
they didn't speak up at all for the kids
all around the city I grew up really
poor in Brooklyn you know the immigrants
story and so all of my kids from all my
friends from childhood were are blue
collar workers who didn't get to like
sit at home and Order ubereats during
the pandemic and treat it like a little
vacation and I saw that nobody cared
about them at all and the New York that
I had always loved was one that when bad
things happened to us we joined together
and we you know 9 11 happens we become
the world's most patriotic City where we
had a blackout in 2003 we ended up you
know helping each other old ladies you
know we're just people would bring them
food or we really do step up the super
storm Sandy was another one we had a
major hurricane and power was out
throughout most of the city and people
really helped each other and this was
the first moment that I was like these
[__] [__] didn't want to help
anybody didn't do anything at all took
care of their own kids all while
marching for equity in the streets like
liars and I could never unsee that and
that was the what really pushed us out
the door it was a lot of things were
going right in Florida Governor DeSantis
I think did an amazing job on covid but
on so much more and I we like the way
the direction Florida was going and we
wanted to be somewhere staying for the
first time in our lives and one of the
things about New York Francis now that
last year will be back there very soon
again and it's not just New York because
the same thing is the case in Nashville
the same thing to even larger the extent
is the case when they're late and this
is what we've seen with our own eyes and
I know San Francisco is even worse I
mean for people who haven't been to New
York lately I'm not exaggerating when I
say you walk out of the door and in
quite a lot of parts of New York I mean
it is literally a human Zoo now right in
terms of like homeless people with no
clothes on the street we were driving we
went to pick a parcel up in in DC and we
had to go out of like the main pretty
bit in the center and we were in a in a
cab somewhere
and we were stopped at a traffic light
and there was a guy lying there with no
shirt on and I said to I said to our
producer I said do you think he's all
right and yeah nanto went I would go
with no but you literally have in the
the most powerful wealthiest country in
the world
hundreds of people in major cities lying
around in the street because they're
addicted to drugs or whatever like how's
that happening in in this country so I
would tie this all back to wokeness
because again I grew up in in 1980s
Brooklyn things were really bad crime
was worse than it is now
um but it had been bad for a long time
and the the difference that I always
like to point out is that nobody in
1980s Brooklyn was saying like oh this
isn't that bad look at the numbers from
the 1970s like we are doing so much
better than we were doing 10 years ago
but now it's like a giant ask to get
people to admit the crime is bad that
crime is bad the crime is happening that
homelessness is bad that homelessness is
happening it's very like what are you
talking about look at the 1980s it was
so much worse back then but who cares
who cares that it was worse back then
then we had the you know years and years
of New York being the most amazing place
to be and that's the thing I was so into
New York and I was so defensive of New
York because it was great it was a great
place to be in my 20s it was a great
place for us to have our kids in my 30s
and then now it's like you can't admit
that there's a problem and that again is
step one and you can't admit there's a
problem because wokeness says that
you're not supposed to notice that these
policies have led to this outcome and
that it's only happening really
primarily in blue areas like Miami has
problems I'm not saying it's not Dallas
you know Houston all cities have
problems but at least they like admit
these are problems worth fighting or
challenging or or doing something about
in New York they can't get to that first
step of like this is a problem let's do
something about it do you think we spend
far too much time talking about other
things and not enough time talking about
these things
um I mean I I feel like we talk about a
lot about crime in the U.S
um and then the homeless issue because
places that are doing crazy things like
legalizing drug use out in the open are
seeing obviously an increase in both
drug use and homelessness and also crime
um and in the US we do talk about like
look your policies are leading to bad
outcomes and it's like no but these
policies are Equitable so this is this
is what we're going to be doing now
um so we do talk about it a lot it's not
like this isn't a topic that gets
covered a lot it gets dismissed as
right-wing you know paranoia and if you
notice that things are bad and things
are and I watched this happen to
liberals in my very leftist neighborhood
in Brooklyn where if they said they were
worried about crime they would get it on
Facebook in a chat you know group or
whatever they'd get hundreds of comments
like what crime what are you talking
about what do you think you put away
your mega hat you don't have to be
ideological just walking around New York
yeah you you were literally confronted
with with who human misery it's not that
you go oh these people are smelly get to
get the plebs away from me you're going
like these people are in distress and
ten years ago this wasn't the case
absolutely which is really what the
point is like it wasn't like this it
wasn't like this for a long time it was
eight years of Rudy Giuliani followed by
12 years of Michael Bloomberg and even
the first term of um Eric Adams no no um
de Blasio de Blasio we were coasting
because even though he's like a super
leftist and his ideas are really stupid
things were so good for so long that New
York was just like free free rolling
basically and then that ended and it's
going to take a long time and a lot of
work to get back to that place and I
don't know that New Yorkers want it I
think that they keep voting for policies
that don't do that they don't solve any
of these issues when is a pendulum going
to swing back because the reality is it
has to do you you can't have you know
policies like oh if somebody steals
something as long as it's not I'm not
sure
999.99 then it's not a crime you go this
can't carry on this is literally
unsustainable right and these businesses
keep leaving these areas
um there's like a major retailer REI
just left Portland REI is like hiking
gear basically everybody in Portland
wears I REI from from head to toe and
that giant business has left Portland
because they're just getting robbed all
the time and it's become an issue you
know they they don't really like that
um so yeah it has to stop and just the
migration levels in the US like the fact
that people are moving to places like
Florida and Texas at such a high rate
last year in 2022 the year that we moved
we were two of 36 000 just New Yorkers
who moved from New York to Florida and
that number is way higher than you know
just New Yorkers so it's it's happening
that people are making changes and I
don't know I I do see the pendulum
swinging because it absolutely has to
but you know you never know communism
lasted a long time it wasn't like they
didn't know it wasn't working they did
but it still managed to to keep on
keeping on for decades so I hope it
changes in my lifetime I hope my kids
don't grow up in the insanity that we
are living in right now I'm kind of I
feel lucky that they're young and I
still have a few years of
you know getting them ready to be in
college and be around the woke idiots
and you know Etc all right well there's
another opportunities this may or may
not end in the next few decades there
you go cow markets thank you stolen used
to everybody uh where can people find
you online and follow your work on
Twitter I'm just at k-a-r-o-l I um my
pin tweet has a newsletter where I send
out everything I'm up to and uh that's
really it perfect well uh we're going to
ask you a few questions from our local
supporters that they will only get to
see on our locals page so uh follow us
over there thank you for watching thank
you for listening and we'll see you on
locals very shortly
you've written that parents should tell
their children that marriage is as
important if not more important than
money in a career why do you think
parents are giving the opposite message
to their children is there anything
social or government policy can or
should do to encourage and support
information and continuation of stable
families
foreign
[Music]